you know I've been researching and
Reporting on poverty all of my adult
life I've lived in really poor
neighborhoods I've done into the dug
into the statistics but I I just didn't
feel like I had an answer to this really
pressing question which is why why there
so much poverty in this incredibly rich
country and so this book is my response
to that question Matthew Desmond is a
Princeton University professor and the
recipient of a MacArthur Fellowship a
Pitzer prize a pen John Kenneth galbreth
award and the national book critic
Circle award his recent book A New York
Times bestseller that was ecstatically
well reviewed in many mainstream Outlets
attempts to reframe the national policy
debate around poverty like the muck
rakers of the Progressive Era Desmond is
a master Storyteller who gathers
firsthand anecdotal material to
illuminate social problems but his
novelist eye for detail can cause
readers to overlook the absence of big
picture analysis or useful Solutions
what causes poverty in America according
to Desmond he answers with Bland
awkwardly worded slogans such as poverty
persists because some wish and will it
to he says we need policies that refuse
to partner with poverty policies that
threaten its very survival Desmond gets
more specific about what doesn't cause
poverty he dismisses cultural
explanations such as single parent
households and declining marriage rates
he quickly dismisses the idea that the
welfare state traps people into cycles
of dependency claiming that these
arguments rely on anecdotal evidence
even though there's a vast systematic
literature on the object Desmond doesn't
take up political scientist Charles
Murray's basic challenge to explain why
it is that between 1949 and 1964 the
American poverty rate dropped 22
percentage points before the federal
government did practically anything to
help after president Lynden Johnson
launched his war on poverty the decline
leveled off considerably Desmond
approaches his firsthand investigations
with the preconception that poverty is a
byproduct of capitalist exploitation
prices aren't set in a competitive
Marketplace in his view they're just a
projection of greed it's tempting he
writes to blame Rising housing costs on
anything other than the fact that more
than a few of us have a God awful amount
of money and are driving prices higher
and higher through bidding wars a
chapter on the real estate market titled
how we force the poor to pay more argues
that it's twice as profitable to be a
landlord in the inner city but doesn't
bother explaining why even more
unscrupulous people don't tap into this
lucrative business opportunity his
evidence for this claim is a 2019 paper
he co-authored in the American Journal
of sociology that uses data so crude
that it really tells us nothing it omits
important costs like the return on
Equity capital and important benefits
like real estate appreciation that
strongly biased the results in the
direction Desmond wants it ignores how
landlords in poor areas are shamed sued
and occasionally jailed forced to go to
court to evict families and must
routinely travel to dangerous areas
these headaches scare away most
investors which means that those who
stick it out charge more the way to
reduce costs in poor areas is to do the
opposite of what Desman Advocates and
make it easier for landlords to do
business such as streamlining the
process of evicting tenants who don't
pay rent another chapter attacks
government welfare for the rich and
middle class and though he makes some
valid points again Desmond is sloppy
with numbers in 2020 he writes the
federal government spent more than 193
billion on homeowner subsidies mostly
benefiting white people with six figure
incomes as compared to 53 billion for
direct housing assistance for low-income
families by limiting his tally of what
low-income families get to direct
housing assistance he leaves out the
entire $260 billion budget of the
Department of Housing and Urban
Development and by limiting it to
Federal he excludes roughly 70 billion
in state and local housing subsidies he
also excludes tax breaks tax credits and
other indirect Federal low-income
housing subsidies the largest share of
the $193 billion figure that Desmond
counts as homeowner subsidies is an
income tax that doesn't exist an
estimate of what people who own their
own home homes would pay if they were
taxed on the imputed rental value of
their real estate the logic is that if
you buy a house and rent it out the rent
you receive is taxable income so if you
live in the house yourself instead of
renting it you should pay tax on the
rental value this policy change would do
nothing to reduce poverty if the
government started taxing homeowners on
imputed rental value home owning would
be less attractive and home prices would
fall this would reduce construction jobs
and housing Supply Desmond has a
tendency to juxtapose the hardship of
the poor with the resources of the rich
but he also concedes that there's no
evidence the United States has become
stingier over time and in fact Federal
relief for the poor has surged even
under Republican administrations he
seems to want homeowners to pay more
taxes simply because he thinks
homeowners are rich and punishing them
with higher taxes is a good in itself
Desmond's initial celebrity came from
his best-selling 2016 book evicted
poverty and profit in the American city
which was excerpted in the New Yorker
the book argues that eviction is a major
cause and exacerbator of misery for poor
people the evidence Desmond assembled
actually shows that eviction is one
thread in a tangled schem of causes and
one of the less tractable ones to
address evicted concludes with an
epilogue that pushes strident policy
views completely at odds with the
detailed stories about poor families
forced out of their homes which fill the
rest of the book Desmond is an engaging
Storyteller who manages to convey the
experience of his extensive personal
interviews and observations he just
doesn't know how to interpret his own
evidence the evidence is in and the
evidence is clear eviction is not just a
condition of poverty it is a cause of
poverty none of the stories in the book
support this contention all the families
he profiled had deep problems prior to
their first evictions some are drug
users or criminals others are victims of
crime most are unemployed or have
insecure low-wage employment without
benefits many have washed out of social
programs like public housing and job
training there are two heartwarming
success stories driven by quitting
heroin in one case and getting a good
job in another neither was triggered by
finding secure housing Desman never
grapples with the fact that housing is
different from other forms of social
welfare because it involves neighbors
many of the tenants in his story are
people no one is willing to live next to
so they get kicked out of shelters and
public housing and turned down by
landlords concerned with their effect on
neighborhoods if Desman were a serious
housing policy analyst he would
understand the trade-offs at play high
physical standards for occupant
eliminate much of the lowcost housing
stock but lack of Standards can mean
people live in unhealthful and pleasant
slums allowing bad tenants to stay in
good places degrades neighborhoods
concentrating low-income people in
public housing projects can lead to
conditions as bad as any Urban slums
making it difficult for landlords to
evict non-payers squatters and vandals
reduces the available housing stock as
landlords abandon Properties or refuse
to rent to poor people and it doesn't
free up units for better tenants esma's
book actually tells an inspiring story
of people working hard to solve these
problems usually with their own time and
money the solutions are never perfect
but lots of people are trying with
patience and skill to keep everyone
housed as best they can this book
repeats the claim at several points that
the majority of poor renting families in
America spend over half their income on
housing and at least one in four
dedicates over 70% which is another
misreading of the evidence those numbers
come from the American housing survey
which yields very low quality
information about family income desmin
should have consulted the Bureau of
Labor Statistics consumer expenditure
surveys which use much higher quality
economic data about households and
actually cover the population Desmond is
writing about from those surveys as of
2021 we find that the poorest 10% of the
population spends an average of
$2,416 per year on housing including not
just rent or mortgage payments but
utilities Insurance taxes late fees and
other charges that is 180% of their
average pre tax income $691 16 but only
41% of their average annual total
expenditures
$3,433 mildly higher than the overall
population average of 34% how do
families spend more than four times
their pre-tax income it's not by taking
on debt or dipping into savings on
average these same families added
$557 to net assets low-income households
get more money back from the government
than they pay in taxes and they receive
subsidies Reon in kind assistance that
are not measured in most income numbers
including the American housing survey
numbers they also earn cash income from
the underground economy there are
certainly people forced to devote the
majority of their financial resources to
housing and that's a problem worth
caring about but they account for a
fraction of a percent of the US
population or much less than what
Desmond claims halting all evictions
which some policy makers have called for
since the publication of Desmond's book
would have catastrophic unintended
consequences if they would chase away
honest landlords and embolden abusive
ones who will simply change the locks
cut off utilities refuse essential
repairs or threaten their tenant with
violence Desmond misinterprets his own
evidence and favors moral grandstanding
over serious policy analysis his stories
actually point to the conclusion that
the biggest cause of poverty is crime if
poor neighborhoods were safe if
middleclass people didn't fear crime
associated with housing projects if poor
people weren't routinely cheated and
abused poverty would be reduced to a
simple problem of lack of money and
could be eliminated for far less than
the cost of current social spending
Desmond's analysis never goes deeper
than his fasile assertion that poverty
persists because some wish and will it
to abolishing Poverty as he sees it
means looking inside ourselves and
finding the will to act his books have
had such a wide reach I fear that this
simplistic nonsense will cause policy
makers to forget the hard one lessons of
the 1960s in favor of policies that
leave the American poor worse off than
they already are
[Music]
n